one final plug because I know we're
getting really along here this is why
representation on teams that are
building technology not agree the
technology I used today was largely
designed by people who don't look like
me who are not like me
yep and the problem is if we're going to
fundamentally disrupt money it can't be
a room of people who all look think feel
the same it has to be representative of
the people that 7 billion people seem to
be 9 billion people who are going to use
it and that is the fundamental problem
is how we design technology impacts how
it gets used absolutely there are
material social political economic and
moral implications and this is the
problem with the tradition we're like I
want to blow [ __ ] up because I'm tired
with the existing power structure
because it does not serve me or people
who look like me
and it's 2018 the fact they were [ __ ]
celebrating that women can be GPS that
venture funds is pathetic it's so like
people are like oh let's congratulate
ourselves first female GPM like it's
2018 we've had female presidents in
almost every country except America like
let's get with it this isn't the word
sad we're pathetic what in the part that
always you know when it comes to so sad
so that the female argument right the
immigrant argument etc the part that I
always have a disconnect with people is
its data data proves that it is actually
true if you have a more diverse team
right and I forget all the data points
but it's like if there's a female on a
public board for example the company
performs better right if you know it
hire someone with a vagina step to give
them authority step 3 give them capital
like it's a three step there goes the PG
rating it's like I feel like I'm taking
crazy pills because I always sex with
her like it's so hard it's so difficult
like how do we change the problem I'm
like
it's a three-step solution absolutely
find people and hire them one to give
them authority and real power three give
them money I don't know that's like
that's pretty straightforward
what do I know I'm just a crypto first